We only have one Earth.
It is a global challenge.
It is a message of urgency.
It is five minutes to midnight in the global
climate emergency.
More and more political leaders around the
world are putting the protection of the climate
at the top of their agenda.
Most importantly: They have agreed to rapidly
cut their greenhouse gas emissions.
That's the most complex and longest transformation
we've done.
So it's a tremendous challenge.
But it can be done.
There are many challenges and just as many
open questions on how to meet them.
But one thing we know for sure: it is going
to cost a lot of money.
In this video, we want to look at just how
much, using Germany as an example.
Before we look at that bill, let’s have
a look at how expensive the climate crisis
already is...first worldwide – and then
we’ll take a closer look at Germany.
The frequency and intensity of extreme weather
events has risen sharply in recent decades.
Forest fires in North America, southern Europe
and Siberia.
Typhoons in Southeast Asia.
Floods in Germany and China.
Yes, they are expensive.
Insurance companies say extreme weather events
cost more than $80 billion, that’s roughly
68.5 billion euros.
In 2020 alone.
Among the hardest hit in the last twenty years
were Puerto Rico, Myanmar, Haiti, the Philippines
and Pakistan.
When the damage is at its most severe in the
countries with fewest resources to cope, the
consequences are devastating.
And Germany?
Let’s take a look at the most recent example
to make things clearer: The floods in the
summer of 2021 destroyed infrastructure such
as roads, bridges, and water treatment plants.
The German Insurance Association estimates
the damage in the affected areas at 7 billion
euros.
And that’s just one catastrophe made worse
and more likely by climate change.
Germany also went through several years of
drought that damaged huge areas of farmland
and woodland.
There are no final numbers, but forest owners
estimated the reforestation costs to have
been around 640 million euros and the cost
of removing the damaged trees to have been
around 2.1 billion euros.
You think that’s bad?
Brace yourself, it is time to look into what
we will be facing very soon.
Well, in the long run non-action is much more
expensive than action.
Delayed transition would be much more expensive
but also more socially unjust.
To understand the experts better, we need
to look at some details: With the Paris Climate
Agreement, world leaders promised to keep
the average global temperature rise well below
2 degrees Celsius and will strive for 1.5
degrees Celsius compared to pre-Industrial
Revolution-levels.
Every degree of warming makes the planet less
hospitable to humans.
If the world warms 1.5 degrees Celsius then
disasters like heat waves, water shortages
and crop failures hit much harder and more
often.
Let’s have a look at these scenarios by
the UN.
Remember the 68.5 billion euros of insurance
costs because of extreme weather events from
last chapter?
That was from 2020.
And it’s only getting worse.
A lot worse.
There are no definite numbers yet.
But - scientists and experts agree action
is necessary and that leads us - to our bill.
Let’s have a look at how much it might cost
us - in Germany.
First of all, Germany already plans to achieve
climate neutrality by 2045.
That means balancing those emissions so they
are equal to or less than the emissions that
get removed through the planet’s natural
absorption.
Research that focused on the costs of this
transformation came to the estimate that it
will cost 6 trillion euros until 2045.
That's a lot of money.
Bear with us.
Let’s have a look at the three sectors which
are going to swallow the biggest chunk of
that money.
Energy, industry, and transport.
They are the most expensive to revolutionize
because they are big, emit a lot, and are
complicated to decarbonize.
The energy sector is Germany’s biggest emitter.
That makes sense because we all need to heat
our houses in winter and turn on the light
when it gets dark.
But – here is the problem: Daily life creates
a vast amount of CO2, since most of the energy
production relies on fossil fuels.
As an incentive to use more renewable energy,
Germany introduced a CO2 price starting this
year.
The deal: companies that emit CO2 due to their
production will have to pay for it.
Companies then pass these costs on to their
customers.
This makes climate-damaging fuel such as gasoline
or heating oil more expensive for them.
In 2021, the cost of heating an average household
with heating oil rose by 158 euros...with
huge social repercussions.
The CO2 prices have to be paid by all consumers
but it affects low-income households worse
because they have to spend more money related
to their income than rich or high-income households
which have a higher CO2 footprint and also
higher incomes.
They are not spending enough money
for this kind of CO2 price and this is socially
not fair.
Plus: there is not yet enough environmentally
friendly energy available for everyone to
switch to.
But there is a solution.
The best way to protect ourselves from rising
energy costs is to expand the use of renewables.
It is a vital socio-political instrument to
prevent what we call energy poverty because
it ensures a stable supply and stable prices
in the future.
And that takes us to the second sector: Germany’s
industry.
The automobile industry is the driving force
here.
It is considered the backbone of Germany’s
industrial and financial economy.
It needs one thing above all: steel.
Not surprisingly, cars are mostly made of
steel.
The conventional manufacturing of steel is
anything but
environmentally friendly.
Around 1.7 tons of CO2 emissions are produced
for every ton of crude steel.
Manufacturing techniques that cause fewer
emissions are still in their infancy.
The German Government - actually the outgoing
one under Angela Merkel - pledged billions
in investment to decarbonize steel production.
The cost: 13 to 35 billion euros alone in
this decade.
And that’s just for the steel sector.
It is a promising way to make Germany’s
car production more climate-friendly.
Speaking of which: most of the transport here
is road bound.
And so it’s back to cars.
Transport is the last sector we focus on and
what it means cost wise.
To cut CO2 emissions, electric vehicles are
an alternative to the good old combustion
engine.
Currently, electric cars are more expensive
to buy than conventional cars.
But anyone who buys an electric car in Germany
for under 40,000 euros will receive a buyer’s
premium of 6,000 euros from the state.
Plus: Products based on fossil fuels like
gasoline will become more expensive.
Electricity on the other hand - you remember,
we said it - has a high potential to become
more affordable, due to improved production
techniques.
So in the long run, electric cars will become
more affordable than cars with combustion
engines.
There are many questions we don’t know the
answer to yet.
For example: Will scientists be fast enough
in developing methods to store renewable energy
efficiently?
Will Germany find a way to make climate protection
socially just?
And many more questions.
But there is one last point, which is really
important to mention.
We talked about huge sums of money in this
video.
Economic damage to goods, to buildings, to
infrastructure.
But all this doesn’t matter in the face
of some costs that are hard to put a price
tag on.
Humans are already dying as a consequence
of climate change.
According to the World Health Organisation,
climate change is already responsible for
150,000 deaths around the world every year...
and that figure is rising.
The air pollution from burning fossil fuels
kills millions each year.
8.7 million to be precise.
That’s the latest estimate from 2018.
And not only humans are dying, plant and animal
species are becoming extinct at an alarming
rate.
Protecting the climate will remain one of
the greatest challenges over the coming years.
And it will be expensive.
But in the long run, investing more in advance
may mean spending less to repair the damage
later.